blad Smiths welcome to the forge I'm
sure you can tell it's a little bit more
crowded in here than usual that's
because the eight of you are being given
the opportunity to compete for our very
first forged and fire master and
Apprentice title this challenge is all
about teamwork but each master and
Apprentice will have to pull their own
weight in order to advance in this
competition on the anvils in front of
you is a cloth go ahead and lift that
up on your anvils are two 3ft long
sections of 1084 bar stock steel that
you will use to forge a
Cleaver however here's the twist or
rather the roll today you will have to
do a jelly roll technique to create a
Billet from which you will Forge your
Cleavers your 3 and 1/2 hour Forge Time
Masters first starts
now I got those two pieces of material
joined because a meat cleaver is a thick
piece of metal and and I've got a lot of
work to do with not enough time honestly
the thicker it is the harder it is for
jelly rolls I've been working with
Master walri here quite a while and in
the shop I know he goes kind of mad
remember your training and you will come
back alive it's not quite in his right
mind damn it neemi use the flat of the
hammer not the round part you're putting
nibbles in it yeah I'm trying to put
more surface area on there there you go
throw that fire jelly rolled billets are
are a much different monster yeah it's
getting a little bit too spaced apart I
try to emulate the best I can what
Robert's already done no but because of
the time constraint I feel a bit
frantic that's not
fun we have lost the advantage of having
a tight roll and this can come back to
bite you later on and it shows up as a
blister between the layers really roll
Fu it looks like Robert is really taking
the time to make sure that those seams
are closed but if the master is
constantly correcting the apprentice's
mistakes then there's no moving
forward 3 two one switch B we got this
Jesse is really encouraging in this
challenge it's good to have somebody in
your corner cuz definitely have the
pressure on out there you're doing good
Zach I'm happy
I haven't yelled at you once I know hell
that's impressive doing good honestly I
think Zach's closed up some of those
gaps that Jesse put in doing the initial
roll Zach is looking really
good go give me compliments deal on the
floor 3 2 1
switch well then I'm doing well at this
point and I decide I'm going to try to
start squishing it a little
bit
I think Frank just undid all the work
that they did over the last half hour
yeah son of a
everything on that jelly roll is
getting loose screwed up Nehemiah sorry
and then time changes time changes Prime
you can come point you can come point we
have 60 minutes remaining remove this
here I got to roll this all the way
around get rid of that I got to take a
couple steps back cuz my skill sets are
not high enough and that's when we start
cutting
wo
yeah m going cut it and Lea it open and
then get that roll Titan look what
nehemiah's done man look at this guy
there you go there you go once I open
that thing up now I'm trying to tap that
thing back down and Chase those wrinkles
good good good good good very good
Nehemiah has just turned this
competition around that Miracle you're
asking for Shazam I think that just
happened D it do it do it do it Nei do
[Music]
it yeah get it Jr that's a cleever Zach
and Jessie they seem to be farther rout
ahead we're having a good time doing
what we
love throw out a ye-haw here and there
you got to have fun with it Y and
they're still goofing around and joking
with each other they're still having a
good time that's great yeah just draw me
out 4 in and Chop It Off In the Heat of
battle you need someone to control you
perfect now draw me out 4 Ines of that
thing so it's my job to shove the
numbers in his face and keep him on
track so the blade starts there and I
need it to end there look at those who's
teaching who all I got to do is try and
steer this mad crazy little
[Laughter]
door so all of those dark spots on
Robert's blade those are all voids
they're all laminations or cold shuns
flux jammed in there can't do a whole
lot about them now yeah at this point
Robert needs to get on the grinder and
start getting out those dambs rather
than continuing to draw out his
blade Close Enough For
Me 3 2 one blad Smith shut down your
machines drop your tools this round is
over you may have noticed that we are
one master short that's because Jesse
had a personal matter that he needed his
immediate attention and has removed
himself from this
competition Smiths welcome to the
strength test our coconut chop I'm going
to test the strength and durability of
the edges of your Cleavers you're going
to get three coconuts per Cleaver one
smack per coconut and we're going to see
not what your Cleavers do to these
coconuts but what the Coconuts do to
your Cleavers Zach you're up first you
ready let do
it
huzzah even caught a little Zach I like
this little beast that blew through the
Coconuts like it was I mean there's
nothing sitting there
anymore your Edge is fine there's no
deformation it's a good job thank you
Frank Emi I know you're ready right lay
on
Frank Nehemiah the blade felt good in
hand your handle is kind of on the round
side so when I would hit it would move
in my hand a little bit just enough to
let those pins dig into my palm nicely
but aside from that good job thank you
Robert and Wes are you ready M
[Music]
absolutely
you definitely lost pieces of your Edge
you see right here the front part
there's actually flakes of Steel
sticking out here and another big chunk
right here some issues but it survives
so good job thank you thank you all
right gentlemen to test the sharpness of
your blade we're going to clamp them in
our Guillotine device once released that
blade will drop down chopping that
bottle in half
or at least that's what we're hoping
will
happen Zach you're up and I've got your
blade already attached you ready let's
do
it it works all right so Zach you can
see that it split one half of that
bottle beautifully kind of crushed the
other side to steal a phrase coined by a
friend of mine it'll
cut Frank never mind should we do this
lay
on well that was a clean cut that just
sliced right through it cut to you can
see the water line right there and the
reason it couldn't go past that is
because
having that bent handle I would not be
able to chop how I want to chop with a
Cleaver but it will definitely cut did a
great job thank you Robert Wes it's your
turn you ready absolutely
[Music]
okay all right so Robert Wes you can see
by the bottle here that when the blade
came down it actually crushed the bottle
and popped the sides I have a feeling
that with those sections that are
missing on the edge of that blade it
just wasn't able to cut
through Masters and apprentices the
judges have made their final decision
it's time for one of these teams to
leave the
[Music]
forge Wes Robert please surrender your
Cleaver my experience being here with
Wes was quite delightful I enjoy working
with him and I hope we continue to
improve our skills together he lets me
do my own thing I don't let him I
encourage him oh
[Music]
yeah